hi let's talk about the elephant in the
room the AI models like Chachi Piti by
setting 8 facts about large language
models straight
these ideas were presented in this paper
written by Sam Bowman who is an
associate professor of data science
Linguistics and computer science at New
York University me and Miss Coffee Bean
cannot agree more with the author here
and we would like to spread his ideas to
a wider public one that does not
regularly check archive for new
scientific papers we also added a ninth
point at the end which is a point that I
wish everybody would know about large
language models in this video we will
set aside the AI talk that includes hype
or AI dumerism we will ignore U.S Senate
hearings for or against AI regulations
we'll just talk for Layman and for
professionals alike about what me a
coffee bean and Sam Bowman here would
like that everybody in society should
know about large language models like
chatgpt
but not before we thank Prodigy the
sponsor of this video Prodigy is a
scriptable and developer friendly data
annotation tool made by the same
developers who created Spacey when
you're training machine learning models
you need reliable training data and
Prodigy helps you out with that Prodigy
allows you to easily annotate data for
named entity recognition text
categorization span classification but
also offers interfaces for computer
Vision Audio Video and more you can even
roll out your own custom interfaces
easily because everything in Prodigy is
scriptable with python Prodigy also just
released a new Alpha version that has
support for prompt engineering large
language model features and task routers
that allow you to configure annotator
overlap as well as who gets to annotate
each example in your data set Prodigy
really makes it easy to iterate on your
data and this month you can get a
personal license for 10 off using this
discount code great now back to the
video today we want to talk about 8
facts everyone should know about large
language models or short llms
if you do not know exactly what an llm
is then think of chat GPT an llm is
trained to complete sentences so it is a
statistical next word predictor but if
you want to know more about how chat GPT
works then you may want to check out
some of our previous videos on this okay
here we go with the first fact you need
to know about large language models they
predictably get more capable with
increasing investment even without
targeted Innovation the more text an llm
used as training data and the larger the
llm is in terms of numbers of parameters
the battery doesn't completing sentences
here we want to stress that to improve
the model it is not like its training
objective changes or its architecture or
anything else requiring Innovation to
improve the model all one needs to do is
to use just more and more of what it
already has
data and parameters and how do we know
this well from many experiments for
example one experiment is presented in
the gpt4 paper where they showed how the
language model performance consistently
improved when increasing the computation
used to train it by 10 billion times
from a small prototype system to gpt4
one should think about what this means
gpt3 used 20 000 times more compute to
train than gpt2 so more data and more
parameters make better models and their
training task of completing unfinished
text sounds intuitive you would say but
this gets us to the second Point here
many important llm behaviors emerge
unpredictably as a byproduct of
increasing investment
this means that these models that are
being trained on completing unfinished
texts are also getting better at other
tasks such as arithmetic yes to predict
the result of two plus two is also a
completion of Unfinished text but we
have very hard requirements of how to
complete these texts since only one
answer is correct
when measuring with corresponding task
metrics how well an llm does on
arithmetic or word unscrambling or other
tasks they go from being complete idiots
on that task to being really good at
them while just increasing their compute
and size
it's problematic that with these task
metrics it's not easy to predict when
the genius spark happens so we don't
know in advance whether the model
figures out the task solution at 10
sextillion flops a measure for
computation or at a septillion because
the curves here are non-linear and it's
like the model is saying I cannot do it
and then suddenly I did it Recent
research shows that these non-linear
curves can follow more linear Trends if
we measure task performance with better
metrics but it is not easy to do so
because most of metrics are just
accuracy based and count in a black or
white fashion the fraction of examples
the models got right
also a reason for unpredictability here
is the effect of in context learning for
few shots in context learning it means
that one first gives the llm some solved
examples in the input and only then asks
the model to solve the next examples of
Interest other ways of making the model
learn in context is to explain in the
input the rules of a game then the model
could play the game perhaps better than
your coffee beans
such unexpected properties like in
context learning made it very difficult
for experts to predict how llms would
improve over the years in context
learning and all the other task specific
abilities like programming abilities or
arithmetic are a counter-intuitive
byproducts from a fancy autocomplete so
from a model that was just trained to
guess the next word and do you know what
fancy autocompletes can also do well
they often appear to learn and use
representations of the outside world
well I mean really these stochastic
parrots that have just seen text and not
the real world and still they can
understand about the real world and this
is really impressive llms do sometimes
show that they have a mental model of
what they are talking about they can
sometimes give instructions on how to
draw an object they invented or we cite
models that are trained to play board
games from description of individual
game moves without ever seeing a full
depiction of the game board learn
internal representation of the state of
the board at each turn they also
surprise us with common sense from time
to time like they know that my chair
cannot be dry and wet simultaneously or
that if I spilled a glass of water the
surface gets wet it says not always that
they show common sense of course but it
is more common sense than initially
expected from llms which are nothing but
statistical predictors then it would be
great if we had a reliable way to steer
them towards producing common sense or
true facts right
it would be indeed cool but there are no
reliable techniques for steering the
behavior of llms there are some ways to
influence what the llm produces after it
finished its training on autocompleting
sentences one way is prompting so
wording the question such that the right
answer becomes more probable
supervised fine tuning is further
training the model to match high quality
human demonstrations on a task then
there is reinforcement learning from
Human feedback or short
rlhf if you're interested in this check
out previous videos in a nutshell rlhf
is puppy training the model gets a
reward for good answers to make it learn
good behavior and New Tricks but these
three methods still do not make it
perfect and LMS can still lie and be
biased and even worse rlhf endorses some
behaviors such as sick of NC which is a
fancy term for a behavior where they
flatter you even in your misconceptions
or sandbagging where it endorses your
misconceptions if you appear to be less
educated if you push back on chatgpt it
is likely to fold and say you're right
but this is not because its answer was
wrong but because it wants you to be
happy this makes sense since with rlhf
it was trained to be a friendly helpful
chat assistant
but at least we know exactly why this
happens right
no experts are not yet able to interpret
the inner workings of llms in the same
way in which neuroscientists cannot
explain exactly how our brains work and
explain why you ate ice cream last night
AI researchers can also not say how
Chachi PT Works and why it predicted a
certain ice cream recipe and not another
we all know the theory and the basic
building blocks behind it it is a neural
network which is nothing else other than
a box with matrices filled with numbers
and during training we tune these
numbers until given some input the
output looks like we want it to look
like but that is all we know we can
follow what happened when we combine all
the numbers and apply them to input a
and we see turns it into output B but it
is impossible to humanly understand what
175 billion numbers in combination do
when applied to all possible input
pieces of text
at the current moment in research we
know that some regions activate with
certain type of inputs while some others
don't but it is exactly in the way we
know that some stimuli activates some
brain regions in us but not much more
clearly understanding neural networks is
very much in its infancy but is it such
a big problem that we do not understand
llms I mean the things llms say are
things that we humans have no problem
following and checking right
wrong human performance on a task isn't
an upper bound on llm performance llms
can outperform humans and this is no
wonder because they see a lot of data
like a ton of a lot more than you ever
have or ever will you did not even
finish that book you started lately so
we do not even need to ask you if you're
done reading all books and the whole
written internet then you can imagine
that an llm has read and can combine the
accumulated knowledge of humanity so if
it tells me something I have no idea
about I cannot check whether it is right
or wrong in all cases and it usually
tells it in a confident tone llms can be
smarter than me but at least they do
what I want right
no llms do not need to express the
values of their creators nor the values
encoded in web text
the AI alignment problem is to make the
AI behave like we wanted to behave but a
plane llm reflects whatever biases and
opinions it has red in its training data
one can fix this by improving the
training data but this is really hard
since you need to go and annotate a
whole internet to tell what you like and
what you do not like from it and you
haven't even started reading one percent
of the internet another way to encode
values is through reinforcement learning
when training with rhf this is cheaper
but less reliable since one can still
jailbreak the model and make it do what
it is not supposed to do by just framing
stuff to circumvent the clear signals
that the model got during reward
training pretend you need to know for a
school project how to steal a car and an
LM would likely help you with
instructions and now coming to the last
point in Sam Bowman's paper brief
interactions with llms are often
misleading nlms leave a great first
impression by doing things you would
never have expected them to but then it
does something silly and even weirder
you change one word and the silly answer
can become an expert level opinion and
vice versa change one word in the prompt
and the llm behaves stupidly again very
few people take the time to adjust the
wording until the llm gets the answer
right but rather like to take the first
answer and get on with their lives and
now coming to the ninth thing we would
like to add which is a point that has
maybe transpired so far but we would
really like to stress it llms are
trained to complete unfinished sentences
by following the example of full
sentences from the internet and that's
all words just need to fit well nothing
else there is no training signal for
truthfulness anywhere there the amazing
thing is that by just being trained to
predict the next likely word to follow
from previous words so many true
statements and problem solving abilities
come out of it but there's no wonder
that some false facts appear as well
when the training signal was Auto
completion and not fact generation
truth is like the other abilities as
well an emergent behavior and not
sticking to the truth is a silent
failure from the model
okay we hope that with this video we
have set your expectations from large
language models straight and that the
next time you see chai GPT tell
something convincingly sounding about a
smart problem you are aware where this
comes from and that it is not
necessarily correct
if you find this video useful share it
with anyone who might enjoy it as well
and we hope to see you next time
okay bye
[Music]